here's a simple question many people  miss  neil is standing in a straight line of  people counting from the front of the  line he is the fourth person and  counting from the back of the line he is  the 11th person how many total people  are in the line  to solve this problem without making any  mistakes it's best to draw a diagram  from the front of the line neil is the  fourth person so that makes for four  total people  counting from the back of the line  including neil neil is the 11th person  we don't want to account neil twice so  excluding neil there are 10 people in  the line behind neil  the total number of people in line is  then 10 plus 4 which equals 14. the  correct answer is c